guys bang-bang
I've got Peter here with me I'm super
excited to do this you were probably one
of the most educated and thoughtful
people when it comes to the geopolitical
world and obviously this is like your
Super Bowl so thanks for doing this for
those that don't know who you are maybe
let's just start with your background
and kind of the work that you've done up
until maybe it's six months ago
sure so I'm the technical term is
geopolitical strategist I help people
figure out what the world is bringing
their way and how they might be able to
deal with it a little bit more
constructively or at least allow them to
make some informed decisions my
background I've worked for think-tanks I
did a quick stint for the US State
Department worked for a company called
Stratfor for a decade but for the last
nine years I've been specifically
helping clients whether associations or
branches of the military or specific
companies wrestle with the changes the
world is going through got it and so
make talk us through just like the body
of work you do right so like where are
you consuming information how do you
kind of work through that information to
make some of the analysis and like the
actual process of your work and then we
can get into kind of what's happening
now but just so people have that context
sure so for process to be perfectly
blunt I cheat most let me kind of tell a
tech story so back in the 1980s we
figured out this little thing called fax
machines which meant that instead of
every newspaper of size in the United
States needing to have multiple overseas
bureaus what they really only needed is
two or three people to send the
information back and forth then we got
email which meant that you really only
did one person in fact your editing
staff didn't have to be abroad at all
then we got file attachments and all of
a sudden you could have roving reporters
that you could dispatch to areas where
there were stories and everyone else you
could just kind of close down well now
we've got algorithms that are actually
writing stories so we've seen this
narrowing of capacity in the press not
just in the United States but around the
world to the point that unless you're a
national government
putting out propaganda you don't
perceive a need for having an
international news presence and as this
was going on back when I was at Stratfor
in the 2000s we had to develop our own
and so we started working with local
reporters and local sources all over the
world and I still deal with knocked over
my computer and we still deal with a lot
of those sources and the the cheat is
that we built this model of how the
world works with economics and finance
and demographics and energy and
structures and military geography and
all of it and we spend most of our time
now looking for things that prove us
wrong it's not nearly as healthy for the
ego but wow it's a lot it's a big time
saver in fact I've got a staffer whose
primary job every day is to prove me
wrong and Wow I love it and I think one
of the big takeaways from your work it
coincides very well with the investing
world you know the best investors in the
world say demographics leave a lot of
trends and the demographics can tell you
a lot about kind of where the world is
going and you've given a number of
presentations now and spend a lot of
time analyzing that so maybe just give
us kind of the summary of how
demographics around the world look
differently and kind of what that led
you to believe was going to happen over
some period of time before the virus
really kicked in so let me do a little
it's okay if I do a little screen share
here of course all right let me pull
this
no car so this is what we would call a
standard demographic profile this is
Mexico lots of children fewer young
adults fewer mature adults retirees at
the top and mortality builds it into a
pyramid and when you look at this
something like this you're gonna have a
very different economic structure than
what you have might have or a country
say let's here's Germany are you seeing
Germany there are you still in Italy I
am still seeing Mexico you're still the
same sorry it's been a nuts sort of
experience here for the last month as
opposed to Germany so here's Germany
very heavy in the middle age moving
towards retiree and the difference
between the two here is that in Mexico
you're gonna have a consumption led
system because young people do most of
the spending and in Germany you're an
have an investment led system because
when you're in your 40s and your 50s
your saving for retirement that simple
dichotomy is kind of what drives most of
what's going on in the global economy
and has been driving the global economy
for the last thirty years what that
means is we've been in this world where
most of the developing world has been
the consumption base and most of the
developed world has been the investment
base and that means the propensity for
trade between the two is extreme because
the poorer countries need the cash the
more advanced countries need the
consumption and so you can have things
going back and forth the Germans are
good at high-end stuff the Mexicans tend
to be good at low-end stuff and some
version of this is replicated around the
world so in an environment since the end
of the Cold War when you've got global
security provided by the Americans but
no real global security challenges
everybody pours money into economic
development and so from 1990 until
roughly 2017 we had the greatest
economic boom in human history and I
dare say for most people in the
investment world this is the world that
they think is normal it's not normal
it's the most historically a tip
period we have ever known as a species
and it was always going to end because
the developing world is aging rapidly
far more rapidly than the rich world
ever did and so they're becoming Germany
but without the infrastructure without
the institutions without the respect for
democracy without the capital structure
without the industrial base as well but
Germans and other countries like them
are aging into mass retirement so
instead of a world where we got
propensity for growth and cooperation
and trade we're moving into a world
where the rich world is all retired
they're not either producing or
consuming and the developing world is
becoming aged and losing that
consumption edge but without building
the capacity to move up the value-added
chain you would call this an economic
dislocation which is very nice way to
say global collapse and depression there
are a few countries that stand out as
exceptions to that the United States is
at the top of the list we have the
youngest demography in the rich world
and we already have a demography that
he's younger than China's and will be
younger than Brazil's within 20 years so
the United States is slipping into kind
of this pocket reality where it builds
its own stuff trades with itself and
maybe a select group of other countries
and say what you will about the trump
administration and there are so many
things that we can say about the Trump
administration one of the things they
got right is picking out specific
countries that they wanted to have
relationships with after this transition
so we've had four big successes in trade
negotiations Japan Korea Mexico Canada
and we're probably going to have a fifth
one with the United Kingdom this year
that's the majority of the American
trade relationship so the United States
under normal circumstances given three
four five years could have transitioned
from where we are right now to that sort
of friends and family trading plan
without suffering a recession what
coronavirus has done is knock everything
off the table and force the Americans to
bring out kind of fire hoses of stimulus
and monetary push in order to keep their
system more or less in place so we've
thrown a bottomless supply of money at
this three trillion dollars in just the
last six weeks that's twice as much as
the rest of the world combined they
don't have the kind of capacity that we
have which means that price is no object
for the Americans suddenly making this
transition in a matter of a few months
instead of a few years and when we
emerge on the other side of this we're
gonna have American security but not
global security an American trade
network but not a global trade network
American reindustrialization and global
deindustrialization
and the demographic collapse in most of
the world I know it's going to be a
completely new system but historically
speaking it's a lot more normal than
what we've been in for the last thirty
years yeah one of the things that's
really interesting as I kind of hear you
describe this is there's this weird
weird world where when Trump took office
kind of this America first type
mentality I don't think that it had
anything obviously to do with
coronavirus or anything that's
transpired since he took office
but in some way we're almost backing
into that out of necessity so you see
things like let's bring all of our
supply chains back to the US a lot of
this trade talk right is the virus is
almost forcing that narrative now and
it's becoming more accepted it seemed
less as kind of you know either racist
or someway discriminatory but one of the
things that you said in a recent
presentation things at the up-front
summit is the Americans strategic order
that helped them win the Cold War that's
not the strategic order that they're
gonna need to be successful in the
future
right like that the important thing here
is there is a necessity of change
because the world is changing and the
countries that you describe kind of
recognize that what happens to the
countries that don't recognize this
right today yeah some of them won't be
countries much longer a little backstory
so the core idea that drives a lot of
what I do is why the United States did
what it did during the 20th century so
we're pulling into western Germany
during World War two and we're looking
on the horizon we see the Soviet war
machine to be perfectly blunt that's you
know that's kind of scary [ __ ] so we
were like okay this is in a different
hemisphere from us we cannot with sea
lift capacity fight the Soviets in
Europe we will lose that fight we need
everyone in Europe to be on our side so
we basically bribed them we rebuilt
their countries we provided them with
security overwatch we provided them with
the nuclear umbrella we opened our
market so they could export the way back
to being first world countries if in
exchange they allowed us to write their
security policies and that trade that
guns for butter trade is what enabled
the United States to ultimately prevail
in the Cold War the big problem however
is when we got to 1990 and the Cold War
was over we voted out of office the
president who has figured out what was
next and then voted in four successive
presidents who didn't care about foreign
affairs much at all and so we've just
kind of been on drifts now for 30 years
and by providing global security but not
asking for anything in return
Americans became steadily more
disenchanted with the world we know
Trump is that not simply the natural
progression of that he's just kind of
the next step on the road whoever comes
after Trump is likely to be less
inclusive and less internationalist than
he is because the economic structure
will demand that whoever is next go that
direction so if you look at say the the
Democratic grip yeah the Democratic
primaries when we had like a hundred and
ninety five thousand people trying to be
president all of them said that Trump
was being too soft on China and the
trade talks Trump is not nationalist
by American standards on trade he's
claimed a middle in the road and the
next phase of this is gonna be far more
mercantil than anything that we've seen
in the last 80 years as a speaking of
China you've pretty much said that they
won't be a unified or industrial country
in the next decade or so which I think
kind of shocks people but that's true
talk a little bit just about why
you believe that and then what does the
world look like if you were right in
that prediction sure so China is one of
the fastest aging societies in the world
you hold a one-child policy for 35 years
you run out of 30 year-olds I mean
that's how math works
the Chinese cannot interact economically
rent the rest of the world without a
global security paradigm in place they
don't have a long-range Navy in fact 90%
of their firepower can't sail more than
about a thousand miles from the shore so
that doesn't get into port to any major
consumption clusters they import pretty
much all of the raw commodities that
allow them to function that's everything
from corn on one side to oil on the
other so if they don't control the sea
lanes which they can't they're
completely dependent upon American
security largesse just to exist and if
you look past back at the long stretch
of the history of the Han Chinese 3500
years they very very rarely been unified
they're usually engaged in some sort of
civil war or fighting off some sort of
invasion neither of those goes well in
fact they're only period of peace and
prosperity and unity in their entire
history is under the american-led order
since 1946 specifically since 1990 and
if you look back to look simply achieve
political unity in the past most of that
period was under the Mongol occupation
this is not a place that holds together
well so they don't have the demography
they don't have the resources they don't
have the financial model they don't know
the physical access they don't know the
military capacity this only works when
someone from the outside forces everyone
to be on the same side that was the
american-led global order and that is
now over so the Chinese today with this
propaganda push on Co vid it's not to
convince the world that the virus didn't
come from China
no one believes that it's to force a
nationalist uprising in China itself so
that people are willing to side with the
Chinese Communist Party in a period of
extreme political and economic stress
because that's what's coming for them
and if that doesn't work China simply
implodes
yeah I read them the book I think it was
a Paulson wrote back in my chest of
15,000 16 and he was talking all about
China and kind of his experience there
but one of the things that really stuck
out to me was the whole idea like that
entire political system and social
structure is built on there being a lack
of social unrest right that the second
that people see unrest like this thing
could flip very quickly and so a lot of
what they do is you know core code
taking care of the people I guess how
much of the narrative around their
driving manufacturing their driving you
know technological advancement
artificial intelligence kind of leaps
and stuff coming out of China how much
of that can save them or maybe prolong
what you're talking about versus like
that the trends are just too powerful
and it won't really actually matter the
trend that matters is their social
control program they've basically
blocked off the Chinese internet from
the rest of the world and they're using
it in other data management tools some
proto AI stuff in order to manage their
population so that whenever you do have
to be perfectly blunt three people
getting together in the same room to
talk about the government the government
knows and can use its army of sensors
and thugs to basically break it up it's
never been tried before it's very
Orwellian we're now actually having a
situation where the Chinese government
is installing monitors in people's
apartments if they're suspected of maybe
having kovat in order to have enforced
quarantine so you know things that in
this country are in the realm of fiction
are are now being implemented on a
regular basis ethnic cleansing is being
done this way forced sterilizations what
they're doing with the Weezer's out in
Shang you know million people in
concentration camps they're trying to
take the best data management tools
available and use it to force the unity
of the Han identity as defined by the
CCP
you know can you imagine what Milosevic
would have done with these technologies
and now we're seeing it done on a scale
that's like what two orders of magnitude
larger
that's the only way that this works and
even for that to work the United States
still has to keep providing global
security and asking for nothing in
return because the only way they can
keep that going is if they can continue
to access resources and export markets
so the the most likely future here were
China holds is the u.s. stops doing what
it's doing the lights go out in China
because the power goes out because they
can't import their materials anymore the
export markets disappear and we drop
into kind of a neo Maoist tyranny where
the standard of living in China just
absolutely plummets and they just kind
of become completely inward focused in
the few chapters of Chinese history
where the center has held its kind of
looked like that they'll just be doing
it with you know webcams as opposed to
monitors on every corner it's not a
pretty fit picture and almost all the
other scenarios are worse so I totally
understand why they're willing to
denigrate their own population to that
degree to mean to remain in control
because the alternative is implosion in
chaos and you know that's the hardly a
friendly version at all that but Chinese
are fairly a student students of their
own history they understand what's at
stake here
yeah before we move on to another part
of the world what would have to change
or what data would you have to see to
kind of change your mind as to like this
is where we're headed if I saw X my mind
would actually turn happen we would have
to have a significant change in
technology that allows people over age
65 to commute to continue to work and
pay taxes coupled with a social change
that forces them to continue to work and
pay taxes
most of our medical breakthroughs when
it comes to people aged 55 and over is
about extending life not extending
working life and that mindset has to
changed radically for us to go in a
different direction and I guess part of
that is a technological change is the
type of work could also change right so
just because you're getting older
you may not be able to go into the field
or go into the factory and kind of do
more of the manual labor but if there
was even something that could change the
way that people work itself that also is
part of that you know that would be one
way but I think we all know that
convincing our parents to use Skype has
been a bit of a challenge these last
couple of weeks and trying to train
people who thought they were going to
retire in an entirely new industry and
that's that's a reach yeah for sure
let's switch gears and and go to the
Middle East obviously there's a cheery
topic yeah it was complete chaos right
now everything from oil to a lot of kind
of the the geopolitical relations
they're just what's kind of your general
view of that region itself and kind of
how you look at the demographics and
what you expect to happen there well
you're gonna have to break it up it's
you know there's a lot of different sub
regions so let's just kind of go through
them Saudi Arabia Kuwait Qatar UAE those
countries the very rich countries of the
Arab side of the Persian Gulf they're
involved in a global price war primarily
with the Russians but not exclusively
anymore they are deliberately trying to
drive oil prices as low as possible
negative if they can and I think the key
in and if they pull this off I'd say
even odds at present it's going to take
about 20 million barrels of crude
production globally offline for years
and they will finally have what they
wanted which is a crude a crude market
where they can set the price and set the
volume over the mid term looks broadly
like they're gonna be able to pull that
off how explain this more because I
think one of the things that you had
previously said was around these
negative prices in oil but what occurred
was the last week or two weeks ago when
the may contract that they physically
set up futures contracts what Nathan
that's not what you're talking about
right though the may contract was in the
United States one participant exploded
Cushing ran out of future leased storage
the storage wasn't actually fully yet
well you know four to six weeks from now
it really will be full and it won't just
be a
what the Saudis are doing is any place
they see a competitor first and foremost
the Russians where they've got a
pipeline that empties out into a
populated area or a pipeline that end
hits a port they are sending super
tankers of crude to super saturate
demand in those locations specifically
going after things like Rotterdam or
Suez or Korea that are popular
transshipment points for Russian crude
making sure that the tanks are
completely full so the Russian crude has
nowhere to go they're doing a this to a
slightly less intense degree wherever
all their other competitors are so for
example slightly tense slice' the
slightly less intense there's 50 million
barrels of crude from Saudi Arabia
coming to the American Gulf Coast to try
to knock shale out that's nothing
compared to what they're doing to Europe
Asia and the goal is just to fill up all
the tanks so that the producers have
nowhere to sell their crude whatsoever
so they have to shut down their
pipelines and they have to shut down
their wells now in a place like the
United States if you do this and the
wells get it shut in they can be turned
back on later and from the point that
you start drilling a shale well to the
day you get first crude is only about
six weeks so US shale is gonna take a
hell of a hit there's probably about a
million barrels per day of production
already offline probably another two
million are gonna happen before the end
of the year that's probably gonna be
front loaded you know that's a 25%
reduction in shell out but that's a big
deal but it'll be back in a couple of
years but if you shut in wells in
Nigeria and Siberia they're gone it's
gonna be years if not a decade before
you see those producing again so the
Saudis are taking a long haul here
taking a big economic hit on the front
side they can afford it across the Gulf
Iran say what you will about the Trump
administration he won Iran is no longer
a net oil exporter they're gonna
actually be importing over the summer
which is something they have not had to
do in over a century I don't think that
this is gonna cause regime change
anytime you've got a hundred thousand
people in your elite it takes a really
big stick to
move that but this is the end of Iran
having cash which means Iran in Lebanon
and in Gaza and Iraq and Syria and all
the other place that the Iranians have
had their fingers all of a sudden have
any money to back it up they're
massively overextended which raises the
opportunity for countries like Turkey or
Saudi Arabia to turn the tide in their
favor so expect a lot more nutsoid
violence in this region because the
Iranians everyone forgets the Iranians
are not the violent actors here that's
the Saudis Isis came from Saudi Arabia
al Qaeda came from Saudi Arabia and we
should expect to see a lot more groups
like that boiling up throughout this
entire region just burning down
everything the Iranians think that they
have achieved in the last 10 years it's
gonna be wretchedly awful what other
countries you're concerned about
let's go Saudi Arabia for a second just
the oil playbook that they're playing
out right now where they're trying to
literally saturate these areas how much
of that is opportunistic because it was
presented by the virus driving down the
consumption of oil versus this was like
some playbook that they had ready and
waiting and they were gonna execute it
with with or without the virus occurring
the Saudis have tried something like
this three or four times in the last 15
years but the market has never been
right now the totally the markets right
the the emotion and the leadership are
also kind of lined up the Saudis
originally went to the Russians with a
deal for a preemptive cut to manage the
oil market back in January February and
and the Russians said no so the Saudis
got pissed off this wouldn't have worked
without global oil demand being down by
2030 million barrels a day
second leadership we got a new guy in
charge Mohammed bin Salman if you've
seen my readings writings you know that
he's not my favorite person he kind of
makes Putin look like a kinder gentler
kind of gentleman but he's young and
he's taken in the institutions of Saudi
Arabia by storm
he's consolidating power and honestly
this is what a king does and if this
works
for him he will have consolidated his
person as the most powerful person in
the region for at least the next couple
of decades
I think he's aware of that this is this
is his proving ground and so far in my
opinion it's going really well for him
yeah it's absolutely fascinating when
you start to get into this game of it
almost feels like a perfect storm right
literally when oil production goes down
they start to flood the market you know
the piece to me that I don't understand
is what can Russia or other players in
the market what can they do right or do
they just kind of have to take it on the
chin and say look we we just gotta hope
that your consumption you know sure yeah
most countries have nothing they can do
there's not a damn thing the Nigerians
can do for example Venezuela is out of
the picture already
Brazil's probably gonna have some
shut-ins I'm gonna damage him for years
shales offline for a year or two there's
really not a lot of things
Russia's different Russia has always
been a master of linkage whether it's
something that is earned or deserved or
not and Russia's abilities dabbled a lot
of different theaters if it's some
things that it couldn't do that other
countries couldn't do so low hanging
fruit Kazakhstan Azerbaijan both of them
oil exporting former Soviet republics a
lot of that oil either transits Russia
directly or transits territory that the
Russians could shut down if they wanted
to there's a million barrels per day
easily if you go offline just by
flipping a couple of switches the
Russians also can use how should we
shoot you say this non-conventional
means of limiting competitors output we
saw back in I think it was October just
how vulnerable some of the Saudi oil
facilities could be it's entirely
possible that the Russians could stoke
some unrest and this or that country in
order to take some oil infrastructure
offline and considering the current
price environment there would not be a
huge rush to restart that that brings
risks so for example if the Saudis got
caught doing that in Saudi Arabia you
can guarantee that the sort of tender
murder
that the Saudis have unleashed upon
their own region groups like Isis and
al-qaeda will then be visited upon the
Muslim regions in Russia itself remember
that the Saudis were one of the big
sponsors of the Chechen Wars back in the
1990s and it doesn't take much of a
reach for them to extend further into
Russia to places like Qatar Stan or
Bosch Kurdistan which are big oil
transshipment points within Russia so
Saudi can play that game as well and
when the Saudis play that game it has a
lot longer lasting effects I mean look
at look at Afghanistan today you know
that's largely because of policies the
Saudis had in place back in the 80s I
can you imagine if that crept four or
five North to get into the Muslim belt
in Russia itself so yes the Russians do
have tools and yes the Russians do look
for the long game but that does not mean
they're immune to the tools that they
would be using yeah I guess as part of
this analysis I continue to hear most
people talk about either the increase or
kind of the rally back of consumption
there being some sort of production cuts
or manipulation of how much production
one of the things I haven't heard people
talk a lot about is the potential to
actually build out more storage and I'm
assuming that's because it would take
too long yeah exactly
is that what they challenge there is
yeah the the most natural most stable
storage supply in the world is the
American strategic preserves Strategic
Petroleum Reserve how that works is we
drill down into a salt formation we
inject water and then we put a second
pipe down that basically pulls it out
and so you inject the water dissolve
some salt some ultra brine comes back up
and then when you're done hollowing out
your cavern you put in crude and because
of the natural temperature gradient in
this bulb-shaped dissolved storage
facility it circulates itself so it's
cheap there's no chance of oxygen
getting in there's no chance of a leak
there's no chance of an explosion if you
want to do above-ground storage you
constantly have to turn that stuff where
it starts to separate or you get
Associated gases that bubble out you get
an explosion danger
it's not that it can't be done it's not
that it's technologically complicated
but it's expensive and it's
time-consuming so we might see storage
this year expand by three four or five
percent that would be a huge build-out
for one year but honestly anything more
than that it's not not in the cards yeah
it's pretty crazy to kind of think about
three to four percent would be big right
yeah it's such a small number of that
still would be big historically what
about India that obviously is a country
that's got a massive population I think
a lot of people especially the tech
community are talking about kind of all
of the advancements that are going there
and kind of you know how quickly they
are growing with internet and adoption
and all that but what's your thoughts
there from a demographic standpoint the
demographics are weird I mean overall
they're very similar to Mexico they're
on the young side but there's a huge
split between the north and the south of
the country the north of the country is
practically pre-industrial when it comes
to demographic structure lots and lots
of children and young people the
southern half is almost like Germany its
aging into mass retirement incredibly
quickly
most of the excellent educational
opportunities are in the south and most
of the call centers are in the south
it's not that the north is a lost cause
it is that this really is not one
country it's more kind of like the Holy
Roman Empire where there are little
pockets to do different things now in
the world that I see coming
India's likely to do pretty well they
never really joined the american-led
Order they never became an export-led
economy they're the first place outside
of the Persian Gulf so they're never
gonna have a true energy crisis the
problem is is that northern section that
is just horrendously overpopulated and
horrendously underdeveloped has been
horrendously overpopulated and
horrendously over developed for 1,500
years now there is no way that it's
going to turn the corner in the next ten
if it hasn't in the last 1500 so India
is stable but I don't think it's about
to become a superpower in any stretch of
the imagination in addition that
northern section you want
talk about Co vid that just absolutely
terrifies me one of the reasons why the
Spanish flu hit India so much harder
than it hit Europe or the United States
back in the 1918 epidemic is because of
that density of population it's far more
densely populated now and this new virus
is far more communicable than the
Spanish flu was so India by the numbers
seems to be doing okay but that's
because India doesn't test so we're just
gonna see the death rates skyrocket
which is gonna unwind a lot of the gains
also come the core industry that India
uses to fuel its tech second the center
is call centers so you know you work in
a call center for a while you build up
your expertise and then you move into
software well they're losing that
completely the reason why everyone moved
for call centers to the Philippines in
India is you could build a pocket that
had a good power connection good
internet connection good phone
connections you build a sir a server
farm you put in a lot of hard wired
desktops that have the capacity that you
need and then you have three and four
shifts of people that cycle through the
same hardware well you can't do that
with Kovan so they all had to go home
and not everybody has a power at home no
but not everybody has internet at home
so we're seeing companies in the United
States who had off out sourced all of
their call centers and tech support to
India in the Philippines having to bring
that back because in the United States
that sort of technical support can work
from home and for every day that this
continues India is seeing the bedrock
staff development of the call centers
erode away which means the next step up
is gonna be that much harder moving
forward doesn't mean the end of Indian
tech but it does mean the end of
cost-effective Indian tech and that has
always been their big selling point
so they'll still have some stuff at the
top end you know the top 1% in India
that's still 15 million people you know
that's not insignificant but this big
institutional boost that they had that
gave them scads of program
at a low cost that's probably over and
what is the second and third order
effects of that right if those us-based
companies are kind of international
companies shy away from that model given
what they're seeing right now like that
capital obviously doesn't go into that
economy and kind of how do you see that
rippling through the Indian economy I
mean we're seeing like things like that
a number of manufacturing sectors right
now already I'd say the big ones are
wiring textiles automotive electronics
and white goods these are all sectors
that aren't particularly technologically
advanced they've always relied on
multiple price points for labor for a
distributed supply chains and none of
them work in this environment so
Americans are discovering that if they
want to wash any machine they might have
to build it themselves if they want
textiles they might have to weave them
themselves
and the technology has advanced to the
point that in most of these sectors if
not all of them once you've paid for the
industrial plant operating it is
actually cheaper in North America than
it is in Easter South Asia and so we're
gonna see this huge scale just pick up
of industries relocation and into North
America in shorter simpler supply chains
that are closer to the end consumer and
what gets left behind it really depends
upon where you are if you're in Thailand
or Malaysia the semiconductor supply
chain system is a lot stickier usually
the crystals are grown sliced cut doped
cooked and built into chips all the same
facilities you don't just pick that up
and move it
but textiles you know you can have a
facility that's one acre in North
Carolina with a staff of two that is
cheaper to operate than a facility in
India with the staff of 2,000 people at
looms that's not going to come back for
it to come back the global security
situation would have to not change and
if the Americans are going home they
have no reason to have a supply chain
system in South and Southeast Asia so
you will still have some of this for
Indians who want to supply themselves
but the idea that call centers and
textiles can be kind of that
first step towards more towards a deeper
development experience moving up the
value-added chain building an
infrastructure expanding actually you
know that but that model is over the
rules of how we've operated for the last
70 years are changing right now in
countries like India are gonna have to
find a completely new model to take
advantage of it or pioneer their own to
move forward and if you look at the last
1,500 years of Indian history there's
not a particularly robust historical
analog that they can draw from here
stagnation is by far the most likely
outcome and especially if you keep that
1% at the top that's still value-added
the degree of inequality you're going to
see in any is going to be huge and that
will absolutely have political
connotations would it be fair to say
that a lot of this is also accelerated
by technology so the us-based companies
you know by pulling back some of those
call centers things like hey people can
do this from home we can you know kind
of cut costs but also other parts of
manufacturing the US companies are now
getting more kind of adept at actually
doing this here in America because they
can replace that worker with a piece of
technology and that drives down costs as
well and makes it more cost efficient
the sort of jobs that are coming back
from south and southeast and East Asia
to the United States are not going to
look the same here they're gonna be far
more technologically driven but maybe
not as much as you think remember we all
of a sudden have 25 million unemployed
people in this country that we didn't
have a month ago so labor shortages
simply aren't a concern right now so on
our side of the pond what's gonna be
happening over the next three months is
our metro regions are gonna start to
open up they're gonna be forced to
reindustrialize if they want these
products some states are gonna be able
to take advantage that better than
others because they either have a better
health care system or a better testing
regime or a better infrastructure and
cheaper electricity or a population
that's more willing to work in a
slightly higher risk environment
I mean Texas has been a boom state for a
while now but in the environment that
we're moving into Texas has the
interface between the Texas Triangle
cities and the Gulf Coast and between
the United States and Mexico so it's got
that multi-tiered wage strategy that has
been familiar to us it's a tech center
especially Dallas Fort Worth it's an
energy sector especi especially Houston
and it's a cutting-edge tech opera zatia
opera with operationalization facility
in the case of Austin so it's all in one
place in a state that has no income tax
so I suspect
Texas is gonna kind of have outsize
performance for the next couple of years
that doesn't mean other places aren't
going to be taking advantage of this
just that's kind of where I think it's
gonna happen first one of the things to
keep in mind is that because of the
physical and demographic structure of
the United States we will have secondary
epidemics from this but they won't be
nationwide they'll hit Denver it'll hit
Fort Lauderdale whatever and you can
lock those cities down our mass transit
system particularly among our cities is
awful and right now that's a good thing
because it means it limits the capacity
of the virus to jump from city to city
to city you don't have that in China you
don't have that any minis you certainly
don't have that in India or Perry or
France there once you get an epidemic
it's going to go national very very
quickly and that is going to provide
Americans with a bit of a leg up in this
process we will in time evolve in the
technological direction that you're
pointed out absolutely but it probably
isn't gonna start out that way
yeah it's really interesting to kind of
think through it's almost like there's a
psychological shift that happens right
and the short term solution is like you
said just putting the people to work and
then over time you've already shifted
your mindset you know you're not going
back to these other areas of the world
and so then building the technology
would make sense one of the areas that I
went about three years ago four years
ago now
was Nigeria and when I was there I was
blown away by a lot of the demographics
and in both in growth and kind of things
that people there were talking about and
how technologically advanced they were
compared to what I thought they were so
I was kind of surprised what was kind of
your thoughts just kind of in West
Africa in general I mean the geography
is so Riven in in sub-saharan Africa
it's really hard to draw any sort of
conclusions my dearie as you pointed out
is that the demographic heavyweight both
in terms of age structure and just size
the biggest problem they're going to be
having however is they've never really
been able to diversify their economy
away from crude and they're more
importantly their political system is
completely based on the divvied up of
the crude resources if you want to go
back to like the by Afrin war that was a
period where some parts of the country
thought that they could deny oil income
to other parts of the country and so the
by Ephron's tried to leave we had a
civil war as a result and now we have a
rotating presidential system where every
few years a different region of the
country has the president in a different
region of the country has the Vice
President and as long as nobody dies out
of order the oil flows and everybody is
happily subsidized oil is going to zero
so the entire political compromise
system that has kept violence in Nigeria
to a relatively tolerable level is going
away we think economic restructuring in
this country is difficult it is they are
going to have to deal with the ground-up
overhaul of their political system this
year I don't see how they do that in a
peaceful manner yeah and I guess part of
this too is as we see more and more
countries get to these levels of social
unrest one of the things I've been
thinking through is just how technology
plays a factor in that right obviously
if this was happening thirty years ago
it would be much harder for one the
government to be much easier for the
government to kind of prevent the spread
of the bad things they were doing
because he didn't have cell phones and
couldn't communicate as
etc but now it's also much easier for
the dissidents or those who are uprising
to rally and kind of move resources and
communicate and collaborate
do you see places like Nigeria where we
know that there is a high degree of
penetration in mobile phones internet
adoption kind of having a higher
propensity for the social unrest because
of that technology adoption you're
simply driven by just that the reworking
of the political system and it's gonna
happen whether they've got technology or
not yeah that's a really messy question
in a place like Nigeria it could go
either way
the problem there is that most of their
politics are ethnic and regional based
and so it doesn't require a huge
technological distribution system in
order to get these people riled up it's
it's kind of it's not that it's built
into their nature I don't mean anything
racist like that it's just that you know
there are they're very clear dividing
lines in Nigeria and some of the big
successes they've had in the last 40
years is to think of Nigeria as a
country and to think of themselves as
Nigerians rather than Igbo or some other
Fulani group I'm concerned that that is
going to spin apart once the oil stops
flowing
but remember technology works both ways
here if there's anything for the Chinese
and the Russians and the Egyptians have
shown us in the last 10 years is you can
use it just as easy to clamp down so
you're familiar with the Twitter
revolution in Egypt I'm sure if you
remember the first phase of that the
military decided they did not like the
Mubarak clan so they they were hands-off
versus the protesters and the protesters
used the internet and Twitter and cell
phones to organize and ultimately
overthrow the Mubarak regime but then
the military decided it didn't like the
replacement government that it was
elected so what they did is they went
and they shut down Twitter and they were
able to do their crackdown they arrested
the entire government and I mean there
was that one horrific trial where they
condemned 600 people to death and now
it's basically a one-party state with
complete information lockdown well the
Russians came in and like hey that was
really cool you did that how did you do
that and so the Egyptian generals showed
the Russians well we have these two
cables that come into the
and that's the entire internet
connection to the outside world we just
cut them so the Russians went they built
kill switches on all the places where
the cables came into Russia so they
could do the same thing whenever they
want and now they've got monitoring
centers at those cables so if they see
message traffic that they don't like
they can go and hunt down the individual
people responsible the Chinese of course
have amped that up to the next degree
where now they've even forced
cooperation with companies like Google
so that if they see messages they don't
like they're automatically tagged by
algorithms and sent to the Chinese
security services complete with the
physical location for where the message
was sent from so a team can just go
arrest the person so I don't think we're
gonna see that kind of thing in Nigeria
but the Chinese and the Russians are
absolutely exporting these technologies
to thugs around the world
Nigeria's great hope is that there's a
degree of pride in the country that
they've overcome some of their past
differences I think that's wonderful
I hope it's sustainable I fear it's not
if we go north to to Europe there's a
lot going on there what was kind of the
general idea of how that plays out okay
so Europe is a site from Japan the
oldest part of the world in terms of
demographic structure so as a whole the
whole continent was going to age into
mass retirement this decade for most of
them that means that coronavirus has
ended any hope they have of economic
recovery a country like Germany that was
probably gonna hit mass retirement in
2026 just lost a massive amount of time
in capital and it's gonna take them to
three years to recover from CO vid which
puts us within two to three years of
their deadline italy's even older had a
shorter deadline was in a worse position
going in some of these countries will
never recover to where they were in
February against that backdrop the
Americans are removing themselves from
the equation and Europe because of their
demographic structure doesn't consume
enough to absorb their own industrial
output they have to export it and if the
United States is off the board there is
no place to export it to so this entire
economic
model was going to collapse in the next
few years anyway kovat has just moved up
the timeframe the poorer countries in
Europe the less well run countries in
Europe the more indebted countries in
the Europe are making a last-ditch plea
for Germany to bail them out and the
Germans like we only have two years left
for us why in the world would we give
those two years up in order to salvage
you for another two years so we are
looking at the end of the European
experiment here there is no way that the
common currency in the common market
survives in this environment because I
don't have an export market and I'm
running out of finance so we're just
kind of seeing Europe and its death
throes right now the question is how
long can they kind of hang on by their
fingernails until we start seeing
political and structural breakdowns and
honestly if you're in Germany of the
Netherlands and you can establish a
maybe a quasi independent relationship
with the United States there might be a
path forward there but there's
definitely not a path forward for Europe
as all why have more of these countries
not tried to create that kind of Ally
relationship with the United States and
you know is it just they don't see the
writing on the wall they are arrogant
and think that it's not gonna happen
what's going on there well there's all
of that I don't mean to suggest that any
of that is wrong but I mean ultimately
if you're just to pick a couple small
countries Slovenia or I or Lander
Slovakia you know an independent
political and strategic environment
where you look after your own interests
I'm sorry that doesn't work they're too
small these countries only exists
because of the american-led order yet
the big plowers especially Germany and
France are big enough to think of from
themselves the Germans aren't supposed
to be thinking from themselves on
strategic issues and so you get this
built-in dye economy of these small
countries who can't look for themselves
out for themselves and honestly would
prefer not to so they just kind of coast
along with NATO and the EU doing all the
big decisions and they're allowed to
exist as independent places while the
big countries make the big decisions and
then everyone tries to play the
Americans in the French off of one
another that only works for a little bit
longer and so what we're going to be
seeing is kind of a Franco centric
Western Europe
emerge out of this a German centric
Central Europe that has to deal with the
Russians and the small countries either
sign up for one of these smaller what
are these two spheres or die there
aren't a lot of countries that have the
strategic flexibility to do anything
else and of those that do they luckily
get along pretty well
so Britain Norway Sweden Denmark those
four specifically maybe maybe toss in
the Netherlands their Atlantic facing
they have a history of resisting France
and Germany they tend to work together
pretty well with the exception of the
Brits they're all the same genetic pool
you know thanks for the Vikings and they
all have reasonably positive
relationships with the United States so
it's entirely possible that that extreme
northern chunk ultimately enters into
some sort of association with the
Americans but that is 100% dependent
upon how British American trade talks go
this year and what kovat has done is
it's forced the Brits to kind of put
that off because they're thinking in the
short term it's probably best if we
don't sever all links to continental
Europe and that delay may prove fatal
for longer-term strategic relations with
the United States just physically run
out of time yeah I guess that's part of
this like go back to France for a second
like the yellow vest protests and things
that we saw there is that kind of like
early signs of some of this order
cracking and people basically saying hey
we've had enough but minor sayings a lot
of that was around like gas taxes and
very government driven initiatives or is
that something that's so separate and
it's more micro and unrelated to the
macro environment well I like to draw
everything into my big theory I'm afraid
that that one doesn't quite fit
yellowjackets France has always had a
relatively status Toccata me in terms of
percent of GDP they're usually up near
the top in terms of what the state
controls versus the private sector and
what McCrone was trying to do was to
loosen that up a little bit so that the
country could be a little bit more
dynamic he looks at what the Germans
were able to achieve with labour reforms
in the early 2000s anyone to do
something similar in France in order to
spark more economic activity
so that France could be a stronger
economic poll in Europe versus Germany
specifically and that has not worked out
nearly as well as he thought honestly
Cove it's kind of a blessing because
it's made the protest kind of impossible
so the French government is continuing
on with the status tradition but it's
trying to make a few tweaks on the edges
it's kind of like we're seeing the the
Keystone pipeline is having to sprint
for construction right now because the
protesters can't get there the same
things going on in France with economic
reforms it's the world one last area of
the world that we haven't talked about
is a South America and Central America
as well just kind of thoughts there I
know that you've got a lot of thoughts
on Mexico but but also maybe South
America sure so yeah I'm a big fan of
Mexico for demographic and industrial
reasons that you know they're the only
really there are the only economy a sky
is that there's now linked to the United
States at the hip and relations between
Mexico and City and Washington are
actually the best they have ever been in
the history of both countries which is
kind of crazy when you consider who's in
charge in both countries but that's true
moving next down next steps Central
America these are states that can only
succeed if they are completely under the
American wing the Trump administration
has I don't want to say ruined but
certainly complicated relations with all
of them and everything the Trump
administration has done is has the net
effect of basically emptying out these
countries and forcing people to go
somewhere else for their well-being so
say what you will about Trump he has
encouraged a migration crisis that he
will probably be able to profit from
politically for quite some time
South once you get in South America
Venezuela dies as a country this year it
was already collapsing and if oil prices
go to zero that's it we're looking at
complete state breakdown famines several
million people are going to die and the
rest were gonna have very little choice
to but to relocate this is the end of
the country as a country until another
power goes in and physically
reconstructs it from the ground up that
is a decade process that is a thankless
task and the only reason anyone would do
that is to get the oil and right now
one cares about the oil and in fact five
years from now when the US refining base
is retooled it won't even be able to
take them as well and crude so no one
will be interested so this is probably
the end of Venezuelan culture outside of
Miami what happens in that situation
right so what you know when we get to
the point of kind of no return nobody
wants the natural resources that are
there there's a complete societal
breakdown do other surrounding countries
kind of take a piece of the land and
incorporate it in is there you know a
bunch of different countries that are
created out of what used to be Venezuela
like what does that look like but we get
a political and strategic no-man's land
the only country that borders Venezuela
that might be able to do anything is
Colombia and there's a lot of really
rugged terrain between populated
Colombia and Venezuela so that would be
a big strategic issue the furthest of
the Colombians might be able to go is
like the Maracaibo basin you know the
big golf golf of Venezuela but even
that's a bit of a reach but really
that's the only player in the game so
more likely what we're gonna see we've
already seen an 80% reduction in
domestic food production production
we're looking at a complete collapse as
in going 2-0 for oil production and that
means all food imports stop so if you
have a net reduction in the number of
calories that are available by 90
percent or more this is an Ethiopian
style famine and state collapse and it
will just become a no-man's land that's
gonna be awful anyone who had money
already got out and most of the people
who could walk have left what's left is
an impoverished emaciated population
that I I hate to say it is just going to
die this is the worst humanitarian
disaster we will have seen in the last
60 years yes speaking of famine one of
the concepts that I've seen you writing
about more recently is is the virus
driving famine
and maybe talk a little bit this is more
kind of globally very specific types of
countries getting hit it has to do with
this food production and kind of changes
to consumption so they explain what you
mean by in Venezuela we're seeing it
because the country is gonna fail but
the virus itself may drive famine
globally in certain areas as well it's
it's it's a messy situation I mean we're
used to thinking of manufacturing is
really complicated with supply chains
honestly we face the same thing in
agriculture it's a complicated supply
chain of systems that allows countries
to grow crops in the first place now in
the short term we don't see interrupts
any interruption to things like oil or
fuel or fertilizer pesticides herbicides
you know all these oil derived things
we're kind of in surplus right now
because oil prices are so inexpensive
the problem we see is kind of twofold
number one distribution when you've got
a robust global trading system you've
got containers and cargo ships going
back and forth all the time when you
drop that collapse it because of
economic recession and shut-ins all of a
sudden you get container ships that are
full of empty containers over here when
they're needed to take food over here
we've got dislocations throughout the
entire logistic system that are not
gonna get sorted out in the next three
to six months we've got to find entirely
way new to new ways of doing things and
the country that had faces that in the
least extreme is the United States and
that's the country with the best
capacity to maybe do something so when
the country with the least interest has
the most capacity you can see where a
lot of countries are gonna fall through
the cracks second in every country that
loses a call center or a manufacturing
facility that's less income so we're
seeing this disconnect and currency
markets with the US dollar going up and
everybody else going down every
international if traded food product is
u.s. dollar denominated so if countries
are taking a double hit here they're
losing income and they have to pay more
to import food this this could become an
a deep chronic issue from
which a lot of countries will not
recover how does that get reversed right
that there's a lot of these trends very
underway what are the one or two things
that could happen that could prevent us
from going to that world the United
States needs to elect I don't know
Gandhi to be President you gotta
remember that we're in a very artificial
period in history and it's because the
United States has provided global
security for everybody for 30 years
without asking for anything in return
when the United States stepped back from
that it was always going to be a
question of just you know which country
collapses in what order and how we're
just seeing that in fast-forward now if
the United States is not interested in
being a global leader and no one else
has the capacity to be a global leader
then countries and regions have to
figure out how to operate on their own a
lot of these countries are food
importers or they're dependent on
exporting manufactured goods that that
just goes away in this new disorderly
world that we're moving into we're gonna
see well we'll get through this as a
planet I guess because we will see
countries like France that have more
independent capacity kind of building
their own sphere of influence but if
you're not in one of those Syrian
influences or god forbid you disagree
with the dominant power in your
neighborhood this is not something that
you're going to be able to bounce back
from yeah it's it's pretty crazy to
think through this stuff you mentioned
these currencies and you know obviously
we've got the situation in Lebanon going
right on right now where the protesters
are seeing currency be devalued away
food prices are getting more expensive
and literally people are just going into
the street and fighting and it's pretty
straightforward if you import half your
food your currency drops by half yeah
and we'll need to take it a step further
right I'm literally going in attacking
banks cuz the banks won't allow the
withdrawals and they will not let them
withdrawing other currencies you have to
do it in Lebanese pound and then even
being smart enough to understand like
this is happening at the central bank
level and actually going to that point
maybe just talk a little bit about on a
on a global basis as these economic
situations transpire obviously the
central banks and governments will say
well we have a couple of tools other
than the strategic moves of
production and things like that we can
manipulate interest rates we can
participate in quantitative easing that
has a lot of different effects on
economies both globally and on the
national level like how do you think
about those central bank actions kind of
overlaid on all of this
I'd actually argue that most central
banks don't have those options anymore
okay most of the world never recovered
from the 2007 financial crisis the
Europeans and the Japanese for example
never got their interest rates back
above zero so when we went into this
crisis there were only a handful of
countries it only had some moderate
monetary flexibility the United States
having more than everybody else put
together so I mean if in a if after ten
years of recovery you've never had
monetary recovery when you went in the
next crisis I'm sorry that's that that's
it that's the end of your currency is a
functional currency especially if it was
a hard one the demographic situation
those countries don't have consumption
the demographic situation those
countries don't have a long-range
investment type of capacity so what
we've seen is the United States was able
to put out more stimulus and everybody
else put together combined the US
Federal Reserve because it is the only
hard currency that matters was able to
do more than everybody else
combined and now countries are coming to
the US Fed for swap lines which is
basically dollar rising the global
system and the more that happens
regardless of whether those actions are
successful or not the more the United
States has the flexibility to do
whatever it wants with monetary and
fiscal policy so that three trillion
dollars no foreigners bought up most of
the debt most of it the Fed didn't have
to do so we still have the option and
take advantage of this later in the year
to do another couple of two trillion
dollar stimulus is over the course of
the summer in order to keep our system
moving most countries can't even pretend
to do things like that so we haven't
honestly really even started a
significant QE in this environment the
Fed has gone in and you know supported
bond markets here and there and I don't
mean to suggest that's insignificant but
it's nothing on the scale that would
need to be
done the rest of the world and the Fed
just isn't interested yeah it feels very
much I think five trillion is kind of a
base number that I see thrown around a
lot and tends to feel like there's a lot
more room to go in this world though as
the US continues to do this is this a
world where the US dollar just continues
to strengthen and we see one currency
you know just fail or be devalued
materially against that dollar remember
there's only eight hard currencies in
the world right now so this honestly in
my opinion this is not all that vault of
a forecast but yeah the US currency has
nowhere to go but up for at least a
couple of decades probably five let's go
through the contenders China wanted to
open its system up they did so about
three years ago and a trillion a half
dollars of Chinese assets fled within
six months so they slammed that shut
they will never open it again they
realize that that's never going to
happen you wan will never be a global
currency and that assumes China holds
which I don't think it will
next the N the N tried to do something
that is similar to the Chinese back from
the 80s it had a similar outcome they're
not interested so they print more
currency than we do in a regular basis
despite the fact their economies less
than one-third the size Bureau it's not
that they've mismanaged it it's just
they failed to take advantage of what
time they've had in order to reform
their system and to prepare for what a
world without favorable demographics is
they failed to do that so we are
probably looking at the unwinding of the
year over the course of the next few
years I hope that's not front-loaded I'm
losing hope on that when I look at
European news these days and that is the
second greatest store of value in the
world and so as that unwinds even if the
deutsche mark proves to be a rock-solid
currency everyone from the periphery is
going to be going willy nilly and most
of that's going to come to the US dollar
so that's a big surge after that's the
pound
you know there's anything that everyone
in the world can agree on us that the
Brits should never be in charge of
anything ever again and the way they
handled the brexit negotiations
absolutely underlined that so they're
gonna get gutted in the United States
with the trade talks
and that will probably merely end the
presence of the British pound in most
people's currency baskets
they're basically folded into the NAFTA
system compared to how the rest of the
world is gonna look that's not a bad
position to be in you'll be part of the
largest market of largest investment
pool blah-blah-blah-blah
but that does mean they lose monetary
autonomy after that you're down to
Canada and don't get me wrong the
Canadians run a tight ship in terms of
monetary policy but a country of thirty
five million people cannot direct how
the world is going to work after that
Chuck in Australia Sweden Denmark New
Zealand that's everyone so you know to
say that the US dollar is just going to
be the only currency of size and that
it's only gonna go up it's not a range
yeah and I guess as part of that
obviously the the Bitcoin community has
this whole bent of the separation of
state and money right so exactly what
you're talking about luck with that
that's what I kind of hear your thoughts
on in terms of there's two schools of
thoughts one is bitcoins gonna go
replace everything and be the next
global reserve currency and then another
school of thought which is as I sit in
one of these developing countries my
local currency or my national currency
fails I want dollars I may not have
access to dollars it may be dangerous to
get them they may not be readily
available so therefore the next best
thing is something that's unmanipulated
because I don't trust any of these other
currencies other than the dollar at the
national level like do you put any
credence into it's kind of like the best
of the worst situations or does that
feel like even that's we reach I don't
want to suggest for a moment that
electronic currencies don't have a place
they do Bitcoin specifically I'm a
little dubious about just because of the
limitations and the mining process you
get past that and you deal with other
forms electronic here currency I'm a
little bit more confident but I think
you kind of hit it right there it's
never going to be a global currency
because you have to have a monetary
authority to have a currency currency
ultimately is about exchange and bitcoin
is just not good at that
but the idea
that it is a store of value I think
needs to evaporate I think you're only
setting yourself up for disappointment
for that but as a means of transfer of
value can totally work so your idea that
you've got some local money you need to
move you can't get access to the dollar
market so you put into Bitcoin as an
intermediary sure it's the same thing
porn rings do that's the same thing that
drug smugglers do keep that in mind if
this is something you perceive as an
investment vehicle because central banks
whether successful or not are going to
see this as a problem and we've already
seen a significant change in Europe and
in East Asia for how they regulate the
digital currencies that will only expand
and if it gets to the point that the
United States is concerned that it's
impacting the tech stake you can expect
the Federal Reserve and the IRS to act
appropriately so careful what you use it
for careful how big of your portfolio it
is careful what your underlying
assumptions for why it exists in the
first place
because the the people who make the laws
and regulate things like this have their
own opinions and right now they don't
feel like they've been pushed don't push
them for sure and I guess as part of
that you know a lot of them I believe
see the technology as valuable kind of
you're talking about you know electronic
currencies or digital currencies and so
one of the ideas that you know I've got
pretty high conviction and is that like
every currency is going to be digital in
the future and where the competition is
gonna be is not a digital currency
versus a non digital currency but rather
a competition of monetary policy so
there's gonna be a digital dollar
there'll be a digital one again you know
a euro whatever and then obviously
you've got the Bitcoin you've got stable
coins and all these different things and
ultimately where people are going to
make decisions is at that monetary
policy level the dollar out of all the
fiat currency seems to be the strongest
and will continue to kind of extend
their lead there but but what I wonder
is if everything is digitized do you get
people who say hey I want the
programmatic nature of something like a
Bitcoin again it's just it's nearly
impossible to tell how this plays out
but it feels like we're moving towards
all currencies being digital into my
three policies were really where that
competition occurs well the the
digitization of the the financial market
is continuing to pace for example the
Brits stopped using paper checks like
four or five years ago it's like the
United States is a roll a grid when it
comes to that but you got to keep in
mind with the overall environment that
you're gonna be swimming in is if we're
moving into a world where the US dollar
is large and in charge but the US
economy is largely restricted to North
America the propensity for financial
flows into the United States are pretty
high basically whenever you have a
regional instability of a flow of money
even as we saw in the o7 financial
crisis the u.s. started that crisis and
money flowed to the United States
because it was the only store of value
so if you've got the United States with
this global reach but only a relatively
regional concern then the United States
will be perfectly willing to throw
spanners into work for any country for
any reason using its monetary policy to
do that that's the sort of environment
that bitcoin is going to be swimming in
and I'm not saying that that's good or
I'm not saying that it's bad and I'm not
saying there's not opportunity within
the volatility but you have to keep in
mind that any money that is not
domiciled in the United States dollar
zone will be seen as a target or an
opportunity for you as policymakers
moving forward so just be very very
careful with that yeah for sure and
we've seen that right now you see
politicians like brad sherman and stuff
right come out you know pretty
aggressively against a lot of this stuff
in closing here i guess my big question
is like the picture you paint of the
world one is very rooted in data in
demographics and over time we've learned
that that is a great way to view the
world but what is like the one thing if
you said you know what i was wrong ten
years from now 20 years from now like
what's the one thing where you're like
you know what this is probably the thing
that i missed or the thing that i have
the lowest level of confidence in this
kind of view of the world the problem
with my world is always time and it's
easy for me to look at all the
structural factors and and draw a line
Ford and tell you where the natural
conclusion is going to be but whether
that's going to be in twenty years or
ten years or Tuesday there's always the
problem so
the Chinese have proven remarkably
adaptive and resilient at learning the
lessons of the countries that have
collapsed before them and have managed
to leverage themselves from honestly a
complete backwards pre-industrial
disaster to the world's second largest
economy you know if you look at their
policies you wouldn't have guessed that
that's where this would have gone but it
took 30 years of the Americans just
basically sitting and twiddling their
thumbs for that to happen
so the problem there is there is agency
agency by the Chinese to learn the
lessons of the past lack of agency by
the Americans and not choosing to act
which means that if the Americans all of
a sudden use their agency tomorrow
China ceases to exist next month that is
the challenge when you're doing a
structural analysis like that there are
decision makers who matter not everybody
is the Czech Republic some of these
countries really can move the needle and
to this point the United States has
chosen not to I would argue that
coronavirus has pushed the United States
to probably move the needle further than
it needed to be yeah it's a it's a wild
world that we are we are walking further
and further into I finished up with two
questions and let you ask me one to wrap
up what is the most important book
you've ever read other than Europe
Jared Diamond's Guns Germs and Steel if
you want to get an idea of how the world
came to be in the shape that it is
that's absolutely the best place to
start that is a fantastic recommendation
I couldn't agree more and then you spent
a lot of time thinking about the earth
and the global economy and situation
aliens are you a believer or
non-believer
I think they exist yes but I do not
understand the transport technology that
they use so I don't know what they've
been here listen to go as far as I
already be thinking about the transport
technology you're ahead of the curve no
faster than light does that mean time
dilation does that mean portals I don't
know I love it what one question do you
have for me to finish up
how do you think this is all gonna work
I mean you deal with digital currencies
all the time
we're seeing changes in policy
prerogative
the Americans are scared when they tend
to be scared they tend to overreact and
make adjustments to the system that last
for decades in a world where populism
and in the country where populism is
rising up so strongly you know how do
you think this is gonna shake up for
your industry yeah I think it's um it's
really my view has changed over the last
12 months or so and the reason being I
actually am very much convinced of a
strong dollar for the foreseeable future
and really because of such a
deflationary environment and kind of
this idea of the relative printing
everywhere else in the United States a
lot of what you've shared and others
that I've gone the podcast I think that
that makes a lot of sense to me the one
thing that I keep going back to though
is around Bitcoin specifically this idea
of I don't need a bank account I don't
need a kind of interface with the legacy
system all I need is an internet
connection and I can access this I can
use it it's programmatic and it's
monetary policy and it's transparent
so I actually know the monetary policy
decisions that we made in the future
because it's just programmatically being
done to me it's this weird thing where
when you sit like how does it play out
that really is kind of three components
so the regulatory side the US dollar
price kind of value and then three is
like the amount of adoption is if you go
in Reverse like adoption right now it's
probably about 1% of the world you know
give or take about 70 million people own
or have transacted in Bitcoin I think
that will continue to rise just as more
people get educated time goes on the
rate at which that changes is you know
kind of up for debate
in terms of the US dollar price like
it's just applied to made economics
right so as supply continues to get cut
kind of programmatically in terms that
incoming supply u.s. dollar price should
rise how fast you know what timelines
people are spending literally you know
billions of dollars betting on that in
the markets and so we'll kind of see how
that plays out and then the regulatory
front I think is actually probably the
most interesting piece of this
and recently a video resurfaced of
Vladimir Putin and somebody asked them
you know does Russia thinking about
creating a cryptocurrency massiveness in
2018 on kind of his uh like national
talk show whatever he's got there and
and the first thing he said is what we
can't because they cryptocurrency is
fully decentralized it's not controlled
by anyone and he was pretty well versed
in his answer and when it got me
thinking about is like my guess is that
most of the world leaders understand
this much better than they let on to
they thought more deeply about kind of
the repercussions of it you see that
again with like the Brad Sherman's who
want to just ban ownership and do things
like that but three is they haven't
really taken extreme measures now and so
you could make one argument like it's
just not big enough it's kind of a thorn
in their side but it's not important
enough yet the second camp though would
be they realize like you can't shut it
down and so you see things like the
congressman from North Carolina you know
saying in the congressional hearings
like hey anyone who try to shut this
down has never been successful like it
is a decentralized anti fragile system
and so like I'm with you on this weird
world of like you don't want to have
showdowns with governments right like
you like people tend to lose those
especially developed countries where the
most powerful military in the world but
at the same time I wrote about a year
ago this weird world of every currency
that's fallen at some point there's been
a change of power when that currency
falls either that preceded it or right
afterwards and it was all about who had
the most powerful military who had the
best offense right you would go and take
over someone in a cyber world though
does that reverse is it almost whoever
has the best defense actually is the
strongest meaning that you know if we go
and we hack into you know China's
electrical grid they basically kick us
out at some point they fix the you know
the patch the hole and they can keep us
out they're actually stronger it's not
so much about offense it's more about
defense and in that world the Bitcoin
networks the strongest computing power
computing network in the world like does
that then all of a sudden mean in some
weird way like the strongest
quote-unquote military behind a currency
is this computer network versus a fiat
currency
I don't know but like that's a framework
that I keep trying to think through that
I think just hasn't been discussed
enough and like I'm not smart enough to
come up with the answer so well there's
only one way it's just a theory -
exactly
and so I don't know it's just I think a
lot of bitcoiners specifically like this
specific role because it's so
multidisciplinary right and obviously
the work that you do you have so many
different inputs that you've got to
analyze to figure out what's going to
happen or at least think about that and
I think Bitcoin is very similar to that
Chuck listen I appreciate you you take
the time to do this where oh where can
we send people to to read more in and
get the books and kind of get everything
that that you can crank it out so the
website is Zion calm that's z IH am calm
you can sign up for the newsletter there
it's completely free and you can follow
me on twitter at at Peter's I am awesome
and you you've been doing a fantastic
job so I appreciate you doing this and
then hopefully we can drive some people
over there and I highly recommend the
books the books are fantastic
oh yeah this United Nations came just
before the the crackdown on transports
so it doesn't do Cove it but totally
talks about national collapse absolutely
alright Peter thanks so much all right
take care